pas que les artisans qui ont beaucoup
travaillé j'en connais au moins trois
qui ont particulièrement au bout de ces
trois lycéens pour cette semaine de la
presse à l'école parce que finalement
c'est votre semaine donc chaque jour on
va faire connaissance comme ça avec des
lycéens qui vont venir nous nous parler
de leurs coups de coeur nous présenter
des chroniques comme va le faire les
loups qui attention premier casting
aujourd'hui veut devenir journaliste
encore ressortir à sanand 10 15 en dix
ans la première fois c'était sur france
3 je leur 50 le matin je crois qu'il est
question d'écriture les loups oui c'est
ça ce que pour une première chronique
j'avais le choix entre toutes sortes de
sujets j'aurais pu vous parler de
harcèlement scolaire ou des écrans qui
envahissent dangereusement nos vies mais
tu sais pas du développement durable sa
sortie en capital mais j'avais pas envie
de prendre un sujet aussi grave
du coup j'ai choisi de vous parler
d'écriture et plus particulièrement de
ses bienfaits car que ce soit dans des
petits moments de pessimisme ou
lorsqu'un indomptables chaos quand
soudain toute la place sur mon crâne ses
couleurs lors la grosse grosse 3 avec
deux camarades villèle et vilaine qui
écoutent mais qui sourit aussi un petit
peu au final c'est toujours elle qui
finit par remporter la bataille
alors quand bien même écrire ne
servirait à rien moi je le passe dans
mes priorités et ça c'était une chose
que j'avais du mal à m'expliquer parce
que dans ces cas là les devoirs et le
dîner attendront d'abord j'ai écris donc
c'est à lui que s'adresse à vous écrire
lui ça peut paraître très vite mais une
question se pose
écrire à quoi ça sert ou plusieurs
études de confiant l'écriture constitue
une méthode très efficace pour mieux
comprendre et façonné son rapport au
monde et à soi même et dont les vertus
s'étendent bien au-delà d'un simple
processus créatif ont couché ses
sentiments sur le papier permet donc de
se libérer 2 et penser compulsive
d'exprimer ses douleurs et ses opinions
à défaut d'avoir un pote sous la main
ahahah le pote c'est bien aussi un seul
là oui mais bon c'est pas mal le poids
peut être un confident ça peut être bien
plus encore même parfois
donc c'est un autre sujet plus près des
avantages comme c'est de réduire le
stress est de lutter contre la
dépression forte heureusement nous ne
sommes pas encore là et plus qu'un
processus thérapeutique écrire pour soi
peut-être simplement source de bien-être
parce que pourquoi uniquement écrire
quand ça ne va pas par ailleurs une
étude de 2013 du jsf dont la légende fc
quoi les gers f
oui c'est un groupement quelque chose
oui c'est une fondation qui fait
kibaki réalise des études je crois en
économie en éducation des thèmes de
société comme ça d'accord et qui nous
dit qu'un peu plus de quatre adolescents
sur 10 confient écrire des histoires
donc parfois dans un objectif scolaire
ou avec l'ambition de participer à des
concours ou bien tout simplement pour
amuser les enfants de la famille écrire
un journal intime ou tromper l'ennui
alors est ce que notre moral irait mieux
si tout le monde écrivait puis souvent
beaucoup de questions et les garçons
habile il ya beaucoup de questions un
elfe et les réponses les questions c'est
bien on peut écrire j -c pas n'importe
quoi ou même pour tous brûlés après
pourquoi pas mais si on se raconte et à
soi-même sa journée de nous on avec une
tonne de fautes et de gros mots mais le
coeur léger en allant se coucher ce
qu'on éviterait pas mal de guerre ah ça
c'est le vrai que sur constitution très
proche du record did parce que voilà
finalement je suis revenu sur des
certitudes un peu plus abordable
est-ce qu'en creusant un peu plus sur le
sujet et quand bien même écriture mérite
toutes les éloges du monde on se rend
compte qu'elle n'a pas toujours été
bénéfique en effet dans un sens sans
écriture pas de propagande et ont
détruit des sociétés pas de publicité à
gré sont constamment nos mirettes et
puis surtout aucun élève copiant des
lignes 8 heures par jour sur une chaise
mais bon comme un mal pour un bien sans
écriture tout les tests confirment que
nous serions à mon offre ouais pas des
communications donc pas de l'être ou
autres notifications facebook aucun
culte religieux à défaut deux textes
sacrés pas d'apprentissage puisque pas
de lecture pas de livre donc pas
d'esprit et ça va dans les deux sens
d'ailleurs l'écriture avec lesquelles
nous aurions pu ré la télé deux cent
mille ans d'histoire qui nous séparent
de l'homo sapiens et tout conte fait
j'en ai conclu qu écrire ou ne pas
écrire c'était déjà se poser beaucoup de
questions
voilà la ligue 2 en moi j'applaudis un
petit peu hâlé way et les garçons où
j'avais quand même la pression